our main story tonight concerns the fact
that summer's here
it's been getting hotter and hotter
outside so we thought why not take a
break
and have some summer fun we're allowed
to have some summer fun right so tonight
we're going to talk about
popsicles there are tons of them in
america and when they get too hot
it can be a real problem sorry did i say
popsicles i meant prisons we're going to
talk about prisons there are tons of
them in america and when they get too
hot
it can be a real problem don't act
surprised you knew
no fun was happening here you remember
what our summer fun episode was this
time last year
voting by mail don't be mad at me be mad
at yourself
you chose to be here and look the fact
is heat imprisons is a
big problem we've talked repeatedly on
this show about the injustices of mass
incarceration
and how little society seems to care and
a pretty good example of that
is the fact that in some of the hottest
areas of the country these states
over half the prisons lack air
conditioning
in their housing areas and in texas
that's the case in nearly 75
of their prisons and that is not good
because in summer
the heat index inside of them can hit
150 degrees
plus there is a growing population of
older prisoners whose age
makes them more susceptible to the heat
and over 40 percent
of incarcerated people have a chronic
medical condition
raising the risk of heat stroke so a lot
of them
worry about what happens when the
weather turns hot i have heart disease
high blood pressure diabetes that's
three conditions that even tdc admits
could make a person susceptible to
extreme heat conditions so my heart has
to work a whole lot harder than the
average guy just to try to cool my body
down
and as a result i suffer from extreme
chest pains on days where it's extremely
hot
i get sick real fast that is remarkably
dangerous
and i would argue that the only time
getting murdered by the heat is
acceptable
is if you've committed the crime of
being a lobster but unless you happen to
be
a tasty sea weirdo with edible arms and
a pile of
scrumptious ass meats that pairs
beautifully with melted butter i'm going
to say
that that is very wrong and physical
conditions are just
one part of this prisons also house an
increasing number of people
with mental health concerns who require
medications that can compromise their
body's ability to regulate temperature
so many avoid taking their medications
when it's hot
which may explain why there is an
increase in the frequency of suicide
watches
and self-harm behaviors during the
summer months
this situation is so bad the un
committee against torture has expressed
particular concern
about deaths from extreme heat exposure
in prison facilities
in texas and while you probably assumed
texas prisons were bad
maybe not international human rights
watch list bad
and just to get this out of the way
right at the start if anyone is thinking
well
come on it's prison these criminals
should not be comfortable
first you they're human beings who
i would argue deserve humane treatment
regardless of what they did but even if
you are fully on board with our current
system of punitive justice on a
ridiculous scale
you should know even some of those
upholding this system
find the current situation indefensible
just listen to the former head of one
correctional officers union
you know i don't have love for these
people we're not trying to make this uh
lush and uh we're trying to make it
humane these are third world conditions
we're supposed to run prisons not
concentration camps
these are institutions for incarceration
the incarceration is their punishment
not not cooking them to death
right and just take a moment to absorb
the sentence
we're supposed to run prisons not
concentration camps
if someone helping to run a system is
comparing it to a concentration camp
things have gotten way out of hand if
someone said we're supposed to run a
quiznos
not a concentration camp you would
seriously question what the is
going on
at that quiznos so tonight let's talk
about heat in prisons let's start with
the obvious question here
if prisons are too hot which many
clearly are
why not put in air conditioning and that
does seem
like a pretty easy fix but whenever it's
brought up
lawmakers and prison officials have
claimed they simply cannot afford it
although when making that argument
they've occasionally been
slightly more honest than they were
perhaps planning to be like when this
texas state senator appeared on local
radio you know
we can talk about this all late it's not
going to change
the prisons are hot they're
uncomfortable and the real
solution is don't commit a crime and you
stay at home and be cool we're not going
to air condition them one we don't want
to number two
we couldn't afford it if we wanted to
well hold on there
let's back up to number one shall we we
don't want to
because after you say that it doesn't
really matter what you say next
if people don't care about fixing a
problem they're just not going to fix it
however simple the solution is it's why
your software update still interrupts
you
every single day sure you could just
click on the alert and follow the basic
steps to make the updates but have you
done that
of course not why because you could not
give one single
solitary and it seems that texas in
particular
really doesn't want to put in air
conditioning it actually spent
seven million dollars on a lawsuit to
fight installing ac
in one prison's housing area despite the
fact the estimated cost of installation
was only around four million and they've
also thrown around
some suspiciously high estimates they
once claimed that it would cost
109 million dollars to install ac in a
unit for developmentally disabled
prisoners even though
the entire housing unit cost just 26
million to build and look
i admit i don't know much about ac
installation
if you pointed at a random building and
said it cost ten thousand dollars to
install ac in there i'd say
okay sure and if you pointed another one
and said it cost three million dollars
to install it in there i'd say
yeah makes sense but if you pointed at
the building and said
it cost four times the price of that
building to install ac in it
i'd say i think you somehow know less
about air conditioning than i do
and that too expensive argument gets
even
harder to take when you consider that in
some prisons there
is climate control just not for the
prisoners
because some have ac in staff offices
and then
there is this two years ago prison
officials spent more than seven hundred
thousand dollars on new
climate-controlled housing facilities
for prisoners no for the prisons
in-house pig farms
officials say the cooling systems are
quote consistent with
any swine operation look
i'm not against pigs getting treated
comfortably i love pigs they're springy
tails they're too big ears
their stupid flat noses and their
horrible eyes pigs are like
big chubby dogs you can eat at christmas
i just question
prioritizing their comfort over humans
and the thing is correction systems do
seem to acknowledge that they have a
problem with heat it's just
they often try to treat it with
ridiculous half measures
the texas prison system even produced
this video on what staff should do
when they see someone about to pass out
from heat exhaustion
if conscious and alert have the person
drink water or a rehydrating sports
drink
do not give them caffeinated drinks as
these will contribute to further
dehydration
sprinkle or spray them with water and
apply cool water
or wet cloths to the person's neck
armpits and groin
fan the person if there is no breeze
okay
flicking water in their face and fanning
them with a clipboard
is just not going to cut it and at that
point it makes basically just as much
sense to recommend
lick the person sweat off their forehead
or rub them with a dvd of captain
phillips
sure it's technically a gesture but it's
not going to do much
the problem is when prisons use things
like large fans and water misters
they only help to a certain threshold of
heat and beyond it
they can actually make things worse
water misters
increase humidity and the cdc has
explicitly said
that it does not recommend the use of
fans above a 95 degree heat index as
they actually
increase heat stress by blowing air that
is warmer
than the body's temperature and
dangerous situations get compounded by
the fact
that when heat related issues occur
prisons can show very little urgency in
addressing them
take what happened to larry mccullum he
was serving an 11-month sentence
for cashing a bad check and began
showing symptoms of heat stroke but
prison employees didn't call ems until
over 40 minutes after
he was found convulsing when mccullum
finally arrived at the hospital
his body temperature was 109 degrees
and he died days later and when that
prison's warden
was questioned about the delay in
medical treatment this was his
ridiculous response if you were at home
and
your wife was having a heart attack and
you called 911
and it took a half hour for them to
arrive would you have a problem with
that
that's speculating i don't know i
wouldn't know if she had a heart attack
or not
okay i would have a problem with that
just letting you know okay if my wife
was having a heart attack and i called
9-1-1
and it took a half hour for an ambulance
to arrive
you you don't feel comfortable saying
that that you two would
would have an issue with that i would
not
i would have to figure out whether it's
a heart attack or not
okay it'd be just bad chili what the
first no one would ever confuse someone
having violent convulsions
with having bad chili second bad chili
has a name and it's called hormel
show some respect to that kind of bean
nightmares and finally
guessing your wife's heart attack might
be just bad chili
is a terrible answer not only because
that's not how heart attacks work
it's also not how hypotheticals work in
this scenario your wife
is having a heart attack you can't just
ignore the premise
if someone asks if you could have dinner
with anyone living or dead
who would you choose you're not allowed
to say no thanks i
already ate that's not the point of the
question
and amazingly as bad as that response
was
it wasn't even the worst moment in his
deposition
because months later he was asked about
how the population of his prison
might be more susceptible to heat
related illnesses and just watch
this infuriating exchange do you suspect
that some of the people that come into
your facility are going to have
hypertension
i do not know do you suspect some of the
people that come into your facility are
going to be
i don't know older than 60 i do not know
do you suspect that some of the people
who come into your facility are going to
be older than 40
i do not know do you suspect that some
of the people that are going to come
into your facility
are going to be on psychotropic
medications i do not know
wouldn't any competent supervisor
uh shouldn't he or she know the answers
to those questions
i do not know okay we get it you don't
know a lot of things
i almost wish that line of questioning
had continued do you suspect that some
of the people who come into your
facilities are fine mutants powered by
heat
i do not know do you have a tattoo of
peppa pig on your lower back
i do not know if you're sure no one
would ever find out would you have
consensual sex with a dolphin
i do not know would you hit bruce willis
with your car if given the opportunity
i do not know what you think responding
with i do not know to every question
asked of a person makes them sound like
a total
i do not know so look when you put all
of this together
prisoners in this country are
desperately uncomfortable and sometimes
dying due to the heat
and no one seems to give enough of a
to do anything about it
and while a lot of the facilities that
i've shown you tonight have been in
texas
that is not because it's the only
culprit it's just one of the only states
where this story has been extensively
reported on camera
but you can find accounts of similar
problems in places like louisiana
and in alabama and in florida and in
michigan
and in virginia this is a deadly
situation and it's only going to get
worse especially as summers are getting
hotter and hotter
and while this is clearly just one small
part of a much larger discussion about
whether and how
prisons should exist in this country
until such time as we have that
discussion
there's actually an easy solution to
this one problem and that is
prisons need air conditioning so put air
conditioning
in that's it i know this show has
trained you to anticipate nuance but
this one is really pretty
straightforward
we shouldn't be cooking prisoners to
death the end
that's just not something we should be
allowing under any circumstances because
locking human beings in rooms with a
heat index of 150 degrees begs the
question
how on earth could anyone anywhere think
that it's okay to do that
and to borrow the go-to answer of an
extremely weird extremely cruel man
i do not know
you